and mixed fears 12 graphics animate Adam
Q it is helicopter polls have closed the
general election is over and our exit
poll is predicting that the
Conservatives are the largest party did
is only an exit poll I think we have to
wait until all the votes have been
counted
well the exit polls are very striking
they're completely at odds with all of
the opinion polls we've had for the last
six weeks we need to treat this an exit
poll with extreme caution
Laura Donald would you believe that that
an exit poll if this exit poll is
remotely accurate would there be any
need for coalition negotiations or would
David Cameron simply carry on well if
the exit poll turns out to be correct
then I think we're looking at the
scenario where David Cameron remains as
Prime Minister
let's go now to sky's election analyst
professor Michael Thrasher of Plymouth
University the size of the swings is
actually lower in Labour's favor than
the exit poll was suggesting you think
it's going to be pretty spot-on on the
basis of these first few results they're
consistent with your exit poll findings
yes they are at the moment it's the same
method that we've used in 2010 there is
a 77 seat gap I think in terms of the
conservative labour seat projections and
that's a huge gap the surge in the SNP
vote is really taken us all by surprise
this is the Declaration in Nuneaton a
key target for labour the Conservative
Party candidate 20,000 it's fast blood
in what's expected to be a gushing
artery for the SNP this evening the S&P
gained Kilmarnock from labour Liberal
Democrats lose their deposit Maddie
black Scottish National Party 23,000
Douglas Alexander has lost his seat
Murray black 20 year old is the new MP
for the SNP they appreciate that this is
a blow for Douglas Alexander
I truly hope he will remain to see his
future in politics once he has recovered
from this result 1716 Scotland declared
so far all of them are held by the
Scottish National Party now 14 of them
gains let's just have a look at those
gains pays the revolution North to
cutting cabbage beep brother
that's it Jim Murphy loses his seat in
rent Fischer is the leader of Scottish
Labour it's no longer an MP yet another
sculpt for the SNP tonight a lot of
people are already starting to say it's
a very grim night for labour and
particularly for ED relabel I think they
genuinely didn't expect the results that
we've seen so far the mood and the camp
before had been relatively relaxed
certainly when I've been spending the
time in the way over the last few weeks
so I think the scale of the losses and
Scotland and the fact that even in
England and Wales as well it doesn't
look like they've had the night they
expected and as a result this is why
sources across the party some for my own
piece for example saying to me that
actually they think that everybody needs
to go as a result it is an extraordinary
statement of intent from the people of
Scotland the Scottish lion has roared
this morning and across the country
douglas Carswell that is the first new
Perry peds related as a general election
were you ever in any doubt well I don't
take anything for granted but it was
nice to see them nice to see things
stack up on the table everyone police I
want hanging all panting so fast
the table is out Tania Matthias he joins
the long list of senior Liberal
Democrats to lose their seats tonight
big thanks to Vince Cable who has been
an amazing local MP meanwhile back in
the gallery and news operation center
camera service moment will we be first
to get to the prime minister above all i
want to thank the voters of West
Oxfordshire who've elected me again it's
a huge honor to serve you Nick Clegg
clearly hinting earlier that his
position might not be there any longer
and the former special adviser for him
also saying Lib Dems will never do a
coalition deal again well if you're
waking up you have missed quite an
evening quite a roller coaster of
various different news noise remember
just yesterday everyone all the
pollsters saying this was too close to
call
is the seat map it's a representation of
the country with all of the different
constituents in these constituencies
these kind of hexagonal shapes but most
of all look up as Scotland that yellow
across Scotland this up until last night
that was mainly red there ally Campbell
who promised Aditi's kill tonight I
think should put on the public display
and will sell tickets he can eat his
kilt and I need my hat and I'll tell you
I've never questioned an exit poll again
but look the real question is where are
we and we are bruised of course set back
of course its independence no inevitable
intake the election wasn't about
independence I made that clear
consistently undefeated we did in the
election we are still projecting - for
UK although we know that things are
certainly dragging out in third South
the Conservative Party candidate 18,000
776
any personal and disappointment I have
at this result is as nothing compared to
the sense of sorrow I have at the result
that Labour's achieved
something odd happened in terms of the
polls which which closed in yesterday
but then when people went into the
polling booths in those marginals it's
didn't work clashing sign their
declaration is imminent in fan it's sad
sixteen thousand and twenty six the
Conservative Party candidate eighteen
thousand a
Nigel Farage that you keep leader
failing to take the seat of planet Sam I
said as this campaign went on that if I
didn't win I would stand down as leader
of UK and I know that you and the media
are used to party leaders making endless
promises that they don't actually keep
but I'm a man I'm a word I don't break
the word so I should be writing to the
UK you get nationally executive in a few
minutes and saying that I am standing
down Nick Clegg is he going to be the
next to go hard on the heels of Nigel
Mirage of course you must be remembered
he's back in Parliament he won his seat
one of the few Lib Dems that did but is
he going to continue to lead the party
we'll find out clearly the results have
been immeasurably more crushing and
unkind than I could ever have feared for
that of course I must take
responsibility and therefore I announce
that I will be resigning as leader of
the Liberal Democrats a leadership
election will now take place according
to the party's rules
as this is not the speech I wanted to
give today because I believe that
Britain needed a Labour government I
still do but the public voted otherwise
and now it's time for someone else to
take forward the leadership of this
party so I'm tendering my resignation
taking effect after this afternoon's
commemoration a VE Day of the Senate off
we've come back before and this party
will come back again and so the Labour
leader stands down leaving
I've just been to see her Majesty the
Queen and I will now form a majority
Conservative government I've been proud
to lead the first coalition government
in 70 years and I want to thank all
those who work so hard to make it a
success and in particular on this day
Nick Clegg this is a country with
unrivaled skills and creativeness a
country with such good humor and such
great compassion and I'm convinced that
if we draw on all of this then we can
take these islands with our proud
history and build an even prouder future
together we can make Great Britain
greater still thank you
you